hello and welcome to this video this is
coverage for them yeah long awaited
candidates tournament that has been
started today in Moscow yeah got the
first round today and I hope I'm not
breaching any weird regulations that the
organizers have put up here they sent
out something that you cannot do a live
transmission of the moves and stuff like
that and even covering the games
afterwards they threatened with some
legal action but I think I'm I'm okay
with what they what they demanded even
though to be honest I don't really give
a damn because this is probably Eagle
nonsense anyway I'm going to make a
video as I usually default do for the
top tournaments for every round
recapping the games and let's see what
round one yeah brought us today I'm
starting with the game kayaking with
right against Whitlam note that the two
Russian participants play each other the
same as two American participants they
do that on the the first possible round
to make any sort of collusion less
likely okay we have the game kayak a
nice villa McCarran goes with in one
night f3 slight surprise he's usually an
e4 player in most of his games and yeah
quite often people nowadays switch away
from one e4 if they suspect the other
time place the Berlin which trigger
doesn't so it's slightly surprising that
Hakan doesn't go for form okay sweetie I
plays d5 which is a slight surprise
actually I mean he's normally playing
goon felt type of setups or sometimes
stuff with C five and nine f6 d5 based
openings he display from time to time
but not that often we get a Slaven and
ninety three the old main line which
will answers with the capture on c4 so
the classical mainline slaw
this has been played before Westphalia
so it's not a total surprise even though
he has implanted much in recent times a
form America I can announce Twitter goes
he's six
this line is nowadays very sensible
alternative for black to the traditional
Bishop f5 the idea of the move is that a
black ball play almost invariably will
play c5 next which is the loss of a
tempo two times or two moves for the C
pawn to come to c5 but White has spent
that tempo on the move a4 which often is
slightly useless or even yeah kind of
counter productive as before as a weak
square white now can also go a form play
much sharper but can yeah kid plays III
the traditional move the main move c5
pass wiggler Bishop takes 96 this
position easily could arise from the
Queens gambit accepted but with the pawn
back on a2 and black are you set the
move a form as a set is more of a
nuisance for white than an acid castles
C takes the form and now kayaking goes
Knight takes d4 after long think so it
seems that he wasn't totally familiar
with all this one he was kind of not
sure what part of his preparation to go
for the more common move years it takes
typical iqp position where black
normally continues with Bishop e7 and
here why there's a couple of options
rook e1 Bishop g5 it's typical iqp play
but note that that week square is
usually helping black a little bit this
this for example rook t1 here the move
Knight before for example can be played
without any kind of very that night
we attacked with a three or at some
stage that the nut has to move also an
interesting little point is that
sometimes we have a situation that looks
roughly like this Bishop d7 let's say
Bishop g5 and ship c6 and here after
capturing blank will very often take
with the pawn I'm not talking so much
about this concrete position but about
the structure Black is very okay with
this isolated pawn on c6 because he will
have play on the B file and this is for
a more meaningful now he with the move a
for being played as before his weak b3
is weak no Queen science week so this is
the whole point of blacks are opening
that he get gifts whites that a former
hope that this doesn't help him
okay Knight takes was played and now
Bishop d7 a ninety form this kind of
play is not so great because white will
go t5 and while this is simplifying a
lot it doesn't mean that black is closer
to a draw and equal equal position the
problem is that lets say cancels and
then White has a couple of really decent
moves for example Queen b3 or Queen f3
those kind of moves and this is black a
black is on depression
yeah because that Bishop is so annoying
on d5 so black is not taking on the
former playing Bishop d7 yeah yeah
kayaking took a long while and then
played Knight f3 playing this this bag
doesn't look very threatening and I
honestly think it isn't it is very
threatening the whole position here is I
think okay for black anyway what they
normally do but this is a rare position
anyway and the Queen e2 is what
sometimes it's being played
this for example is a possible way to
continue this is this monkey one cancels
and 27 this for example has been played
last year in a game between the cumin
and the minion GM and Micky Adams in the
it was this is the PokerStars tournament
right that a huge open on the Isle of
Man ultimately Mancunian won that game
but black is certainly ok him yeah
neither three years a new move by
kayaking but not part of home prep he
just thought about this over the board
yes Peter now play some very common set
up a six queen goes to c7 and Bishop to
d6 yeah a black now gets in this typical
Knight to e5 move and the structure is
well known from the Queens gambit
accepted and similar openings black is
okay yeah why term now goes for activity
that was what he had planned with a set
up and black gives the check and black
can take the pawn by the way it's not
like it's clear Liam it's clearly
reviewed it but it is definitely
dangerous to do so I mean there should
be two white has some yeah some strong
activity even though the computers are
not saying that white is better or
anything it just is very unhuman
decision yeah to to tell you to grab
such upon especially considering that
Bishop d4 check is simply okay yeah
Bishop III bond kayaking and now Sweden
I crept only three and play d5 it's very
logical setup white now has this Bishop
Hampden and this is the reason why if I
was played if why white would get in a
five then all of a sudden his pieces
would would spring to life
so this is a lot better let go see five
and tea I think
White has to be content with something
close to equal maybe well I'd rather be
Blacky already but it's nothing nothing
dramatic what why definitely cannot do
is play something ambitious like f5
Bishop c64 yeah this is this kind of
play will probably backfire because what
is mostly weakening himself here with
this kind of yeah
aggressive demonstration he has to be be
content with an equal solid play rooks
e1 is good I think
threatening possible Knight to d5 in
Laos with Legree from f4 so that we got
an endgame yeah now Bishop e6 was played
that's a good move Bishop c6 also looks
very natural but after Bishop to c4 we
see that clearly this pressure would be
5 maybe also on the cards is a little
bit annoying but should be 6 make sure
that the bishop is not coming to see
form good move yeah King f2 rook c8 oops
King III 97 yeah I think that black is
slightly more comfortable because his
pawn structure is more compact it's
difficult for white to ever get to one
of the pause this is totally safely on
the King side and also those pawns are
hard to reach while White's pawns on a 4
B 4 B - they are slightly weakened so I
think black is certainly comfortable
yeah that went back through p8 you
should be too and maybe here you can try
to find better moves than sweedler play
deep late night to b6 the computers like
rooks is 6 or 95 year and those moves
indeed might be a little bit more
testing in a rock c6 for example
oops I'm sorry and why places and now
rooks is six for example can lead to
interesting play at Group D 195 and now
I finally moved in by the engines Knight
b5 yeah
the computers just suggest a completely
wacky line this is a suggested by
stockfish which is utterly inhuman yeah
it not be three I'm just showing you the
line without telling you much about it
just it is just sometimes crazy what the
computers come up with yeah absolutely
nobody would play like that like this
and at the end and why it is probably
getting enough how to play to to draw
yeah it's just a totally unforced line
it just shows that some interesting
possibilities there
there's also Knight c5 that that black
can think about also eyeing this eyeing
this square it's nothing serious but I
think here was maybe an idea but there
were some possibility for Sevilla to try
something at least I cannot really shake
off the feeling that if you give that
position with black to two cards and
hippo torches opponent for 15 mumbles in
this game or Adam Knight b6 was played
Chang let's see for get this traded and
this and here draw was agreed they have
to play 30 moves I think in this
tournament to agree to a draw so this is
kind of fitting even though I mean the
position here is very very equal and
there's nothing yeah it's just a normal
decision now to agree to a draw it's
also have to take into account that this
is a very long tournament and it doesn't
really help to continue in some very
draws position that they probably will
just waste your energy with
so I feel pretty correct to draw sweet I
didn't have any problems here with black
again skyrocket maybe maybe he could
have tried a little bit a little bit
harder but yeah he's absolutely not to
blame for being solid with black in the
first round of that event the next game
I wanted shake is Nakamura Caruana two
American players and Khurana goes whoa
sorry naka muka plays once he fall yeah
currently popular moves on the top level
because the mainline openings if I
deform they sometimes get a bit stale in
view of some lines that black equalizes
will so they experiment a little bit
more here with 1c form we get this on
the bottom symmetrical line very sound
choice here by back koala and now my
camera very early on and goes for
something unconventional we plays III
the ideas of course not new
revolutionary or anything but usually it
is played like that and it has the
reputation of being a very very young
yeah sound solid but also boring line
this III however it's a little bit
different as White has not played the
move Knight c3 and black also hasn't and
this makes things a little bit different
as a possible d4 for example wouldn't
threaten or carry the idea of playing d5
to attack that annoyed yeah koala is
just playing a symmetrical way after
quite some quite some thought and it's
certainly decent choice deform
take stakes and now Knight to e7 of
course you can argue that d5 could be
played immediately I'm not quite sure
why it was avoided it would seem to be a
pretty logical choice one reason why
this III line is deemed so boring is
this kind of position that can also
arise with them the Knights being out
already and with those those moves and
so did I have got their effects on the
board with black cap against people we
really just want to bore the hell out of
you yeah okay it didn't happen in this
game Kawana played 97 preparing d5 and
Nakamura now played d4 d5 to avoid that
and played quickly so this is part of
his preparation it's interesting that he
actually has prepared this line a knight
c3 very normal move Knight to d7 yeah
the black problem I mean not that his
verse I'm not saying that at all but the
the issue that he has is that this pawn
is restricting pieces a little bit c66
those squares are covered so he cannot
easily play knight c6 he has to more or
less play ninety seven note that this is
an open diagonal this is a big
difference to the white bishop the white
bishop is looking at that d5 pawn and
seems rather passive in comparison black
bishop is more active on the other hand
as I said white dis control some squares
you put that pawn on d5
yeah ninety seven ninety three castles
castles age six age six is a bit of a
mysterious move but I think the idea
could really be that black wants to be
ready to play the move g5 under
favourable circumstances
favorable circumstances mean maybe as an
answer to bishop to have form in a
situation where Haiti six is not hanging
yeah so for example this this was played
yeah Nakamura was immediately yeah
getting rid of any g65 possibilities but
if you imagine why it would play this
for example 9f5
and I know look see one and some normal
moves then this could be an option
yeah with the white Bishop being forced
back I don't think that this is a
particularly weakening setup for black
it could be rather okay act like this
for example and it continues okay the
white moves in specially rooks see one
look a little bit silly but this could
be the idea so age form was played not
so much with an attack in mind on the
kingside but just to control G 595 by
black activating the nitro p1 Bishop g4
all this fields very very natural Queen
d2 yeah starting here we might check
possible alternatives for black what
Koala is playing it only now see the
clock times the clock times I think are
not super precise iam from that from
that Isis yeah but it's it's close to
the truth I saw a little bit of the
broadcast today now camera was clearly
head on the clock so it's remarkable
maybe he's making out really beats the
preparation candy it looks a bit weird
but maybe it was just playing quickly
and trying to build up pressure on the
clock with somewhat normal-looking moves
that cannot be bad anyway I'm getting at
the falling now black setup is probably
not so great
karana took here and played Queen to f6
the ideas to get night to d4
probably this is not such a brilliant
idea
because in the game Nakamura gets some
advantage yeah what else is there a
couple of options black can play Queen
to b6 for example and trying to activate
the Queen a little bit in this way
why doesn't have a totally obvious reply
he can um try to you know play a
non-committal move but then black will
probably play a rook to e8 I'm going to
show which one at this one the other one
it probably doesn't matter that much
and I think black is kind of came the
game continuation doesn't look bad but
the problem is a little bit that after
rook c1 this is what happened the move
before is annoying trying to push the
knight back and then Knight e4 is also
coming so here karana felt obliged to
play a five which is not an easy
decision because it weakens to be five
square so much maybe yeah
maybe add something else but don't
exactly ask me what it should be
if he goes Knight to deform white will
just look back and there is no clear
idea behind 934 now you probably have to
play that anyway they are note that this
is not a problem
yeah well we played a5 and I think after
that what has what has something
definitely played Knight d5 attacking
that pawn and allowing black to capture
them which is what Caruana did it's
there's really no other if you don't
grab it yeah it would just be a position
where blacks under pressure and you did
you take
so couldn't be to got traded whoopsy to
attacking this and push it back to f6
and now we come to a critical position
of the game what my camera is playing is
certainly keeping an advantage but White
has alternatives here that are quite
interesting and I must say I'm not
totally sure about about it I mean I
looked at this cost using the help of of
an engine but it didn't give a
completely clear picture the engine's
best smooth or suppose the best move is
look to d1 which is kind of remarkable
that the rook is leaving the open file
but it controls deform and keeps this
under attack the ideas to play also
Bishop g4 then maybe take then take the
six I also had a look at this move and
something that the computer doesn't like
at all but looks very very normal and
again this is not giving a totally clear
picture black can't play the move 93
here but this is not entirely clear to
me for example after route D 1 what was
my line Knight f4 Knight f5 GT x and G
takes we have a position where we have
opposite colored bishops and this in
general should yeah should help the
defender a little bit hard to say in
general right yeah but you could assume
that the defender is the site benefiting
from that but it's not clear here at all
y definitely has has chances here to
push and it's it also looks like if you
look at something like that
for example the Dwight will get the pawn
all the way to the seven so yeah I don't
like that so much
instead of 93 probably back the move
Knight to g4 is the more interesting
option
this also is probably the more obvious
move it looks at this and this yeah
rooks e3 and here it's interesting to
note that the move 92 is probably wrong
it looks totally normal but I think the
resulting position seems good for white
this this Bishop h6 Google d8 and 95 I
think here a black is under some serious
pressure for example like like push it
back but should be 397 or d6 something
like that it's just awkward yeah White
has an excellent plane for the exchange
in the form of the bishop pea the
strongest exponent this is the
completely worthless pawn so difficult
very difficult for black to handle he
probably should avoid the move Knight to
check the move given by the computers on
his rook a to d8 very young yeah very
cool move in a way a black is accepting
that this is still hanging because he
has this tactic and he at some point
might even play g5 to get rid of the
support of this annoyed um yeah how does
it continue afternoon 88 um yeah engine
gives King G - yeah
running out of possible on getting out
of possible checks and now it's funny
the computer gives us the best move that
completely weird-looking move from that
d26
I mean okay it it attacks this but it
still looks very funny after Bishop to
you fire for white
this entirely weird line Jack ends in a
position where black it's maybe still a
little bit worse but should be able to
hold there we already have somewhat
reduce material count him so 1986
ultimately it's maybe not so convincing
but the main suggestion of the computer
work t1 is quite annoying from black
yeah look ft 8 yeah
covering d6 and then Bishop g4 this is
the key move that makes blacks life
somewhat awkward g5 drastic measure but
otherwise it's even worse there's this
and this is the line given by them by
the Stockbridge engine and I was a bit
surprised to see that the computer
language this position as more than one
point for white like one point one pawn
I mean it's clear that why this is
better but one pawn sounds and sounds
like a lot it's definitely a very
awkward position very awkward position
to play and this was the the alternative
here form the Nakamura to go for that
dead rook t1 yeah he decided to take
with the bishop which also keeps an
advantage don't get me wrong
yeah takes oops that was the wrong
button takes takes and and b6 yeah and
here he went rook to be one attacking
that pole 8 and probably the next move
is the move that is ins life for black
95 seems to be better going for later d6
Bishop c6 maybe white is essentially
playing a pawn up as the bleep horn is
so reliably stopped through the night
being on b5 his move looks very normal
like night C for attacking be 6 but
koala has them move Knight a form and
this is all of a sudden not so easy to
tackle yeah how is that night going to
be arrest it's not easy at all and black
has a clear plan this and the route to
d8 and now after d6 and beep h5 I'm
sorry
and now b5 it all basically evaporated
to a draw probably around here there are
still possibilities around him for Y to
be more yeah to be more testing and one
idea could be h5 maybe try to loosen up
the the King side our King g7 and t6
yeah but that's also Rudi 8 it's
probably not a big difference I think
the worst is already over for black that
move rook t1 really am would have put
karana to a very difficult test in the
first round
yeah I said the way it went we had this
and only very shortly afterwards here
they agreed to a draw which is yeah kind
of understandable we have a position
where simply nothing happens I mean
black can't just play 95 and how many
will play 95 after which we have this
traded down and even those two pawns
will come up the board pretty quickly so
a draw for the two American participants
Tamura definitely had some chances him
to press quite hard but he wasn't
probably precise enough in the in the
very critical very critical moment okay
the next game to check is Geary aronia
okay let's see what happened here we
have a twins gambit declined an opening
that yes somehow could have been
expected during plays both Evo and d4
but more often that not he plays d4 and
Queens gambit is one of Ronan's main
defenses okay all this we know and not
be g7 is the modern mainline yeah
nowadays it's pretty clear that white
should go with c5 in order to fight for
an advantage not very surprising to me I
have to say when I studied this opening
like five six years ago when I made this
black system part of my opening
repertoire I was also thinking that only
c5 can endanger black the main point is
that if Y does not play c5 black will
play c5 himself and it's very hard for
white to get anything out of a position
like this where here where black yeah
it's very easy ideas like this this 9 to
6 this is just um not much at all yeah
so c5
um it's nowadays the mainline c6h three
white as some making useful moves try to
delay the development of the King's
Bishop a5 a3 black gained some ground on
the Queen side and prepares the trade of
his problem piece if you can solve this
issue
the Queens gambit declined of the issue
of the bishop on c8 normally you
equalize with black here Bishop a6 is
playable but often leading to quite
murky play after this yeah looks very
very dangerous at first it's not that
dangerous but it is it is an issue
quincy 8 has to be played yeah
night-night b8 is not a good idea
quincy 8 is the point and now white can
see 7 before 1 and b5
it's a it's a very complicated line
black nowadays has improved on that and
Aronian plays this movement aged 6 black
just waits and and chance white okay
what are you going to do next and what
is essentially running out of decent
waiting moves he now has to move the
bishop on f1 Bishop d3 and now Bishop e6
of course white can do the same now like
this this this but it is definitely a
useful tempo to have at age 6 move okay
I don't want to go into this in much
detail castles and now we get this very
standard position on the board I've also
had this lot myself with with both
colors in blitz games usual take is that
black should be okay black is slightly
slightly passive but also very very
solid and difficult to break down I
think Gary is actually doing a pretty
good job here in creating something he
regroups the night and black goes for a
trade of that Bishop 93 that roster idea
of 91 and now after the capture he takes
with the e pawn
this is the far more interesting way to
play getting this double pawn
however the pawns are not weak at all
and this ff4 default pants they make
absolutely clear that black is never
going to play 625 yeah and that's it
white is a little bit more comfortable
even though it shouldn't be terrible for
black so we see what happens
look 282 this now
f3 the knight is kicked back and Aronian
decides to first simplify the position a
bit and now b5 is played this is the
scenario that happens quite often in
this line white gets this on the board
and tries to build up some tension here
with those pawns I mean it's a one way
to phrase it there is some tension but
try to use this tension to his advantage
um yeah rook c8 now by Aronian looks
normal
it's not a good idea to take because of
c6 that doesn't win material but the
problem is that something like this is
very awkward to fighting this pawn so
you played rook c8 and now creature a4
yeah what definitely has some pressure
Queen c7 was played black had
alternatives he also could have taken
here immediately like this and then yeah
that was an idea that I had then the
group c7 just staying the problem is a
little bit like an cg form 26 that we
get a slightly worse version of the game
of the night before and c6 yeah this is
this is all a little bit better for
white but it's very difficult to say if
it's something substantial I think in
comparison what aronia did is bad I act
just Queen to c7
and now um gap black tries to take on c5
and b5 so the white capture is pretty
logical this this this yeah
and in this position I think Gary could
play Knight to before and I'm not
completely sure why he didn't I mean
okay what he played also keeps an edge
but in my mind this looks more dangerous
but maybe I'm wrong it's very difficult
to judge so rook c8 back c6 aside yeah
now white gets his pawn yeah I know
maybe something something like that I
mean here white definitely is better
but can you win this is the other thing
and it might come here I doesn't look
good I know I probably would have played
that but giving us like 10 times better
technically than I am so it's sad to say
I mean what he does as I said keeps
keeps pressure it's not like it's bad he
played rook c1 I'm just pointing out the
alternative that I felt was interesting
yeah rooks e7 and 93 after Knight c3
black actually has a surprising
possibility that is pointed out by the
by the engine and it's something that
Aronian does not go for takes takes he
now plays the move Knight to e8
basically deciding to try to hold the
position by yeah passive defense what he
could have done is he could have
actually taken this looks very strange
at first because you sing you think that
not b5 just wins material however black
has the surprising move well surprising
it's the only move but it's not so easy
to foresee this one
he just keeps this yeah he just lets
white take the rope and now it takes on
d3 and the funny situation is it's a
fork
those two pawns so like rook a one night
F form and here black is completely fine
and it's it's also pretty simple to play
you can very easily set up a position
with black let's say with g5 King g7 and
95 or so when you cover f7 as your only
imaginable weakness and then you just
stay and do nothing forever ever it's a
pretty straightforward and easy draw
I think Aronian simply did not see that
possibility otherwise he would have gone
for it after 98 he still has to suffer a
lot yeah a lot this may be strong but he
has to be very very precise and defense
night b5 oopsie 8 I'm King f2 a King
King comes up it just does not look very
comfortable but in the further course of
the game neither the engined north nor
give me no me we didn't find a way
forward
I mean why this definitely having
pressure but can you win this the thing
might be a good regrouping and I will be
7 not this this is the wrong idea here
white will get you to double team rook
is very unfortunate there on c6 rupee 7
though it's a lot stronger and king c3
yeah if white plays this move jack this
is happening quite embarrassing it's
gone so king c3 is better King to e7
okay one yeah white is still pressing
but it seems to be that there is no
clear way forward I don't want to look
at this in in any big detail it's
still a couple of moves I just want to
point out one particular situation that
is not quite interesting so g5 not
sitting there passively for the rest of
the game probably a good decision by
aronia and a key moment is here when
this is channel played to a rook ending
at first the next move now it's very
very strong
by Ronan yet foreseen that he has to
move rook to f4 and this is effectively
ending the game it's very very nicely
played why is it ending the game okay
you offer the rook trade and White has
no real way to avoid it now if he plays
gap and it would be five or so yeah
black will go G form and completely
clarify the Kings side I mean there's
nothing happening simply if white is
going somewhere else yeah this third
rooks you fall is also hanging
anyway black can go here head this is
also always an issue that will
completely yeah I get blacks play on the
kingside started so the rook trade is
the thing takes a king before King D
seven King e5 and King to c6 yeah
King f4 now has to be played and this is
not a good idea
Sun King takes King takes e5 and Aronian
basically had to see this when he played
rook f7m more or less as after that rook
a6 reply by Gary you more than have to
take I mean you had to foresee all that
and this key and pawn ending that we now
have on the board it is a draw it really
is but you have to be yeah you have to
understand a certain concept here to
prove it's a draw it's by the way
something that computer engines don't
understand they give white almost
decisive advantage here would seem and
what it is it's
one thing that computers still don't get
a fortress yeah
give you Angie for King back here by
Aronian and King III the move g5 is also
not leading to anything just black can
take and now play King to the seventh
yeah qt7 a fourth you have six King III
and if I and four and it will end in the
draw
yeah this was played it's also a little
bit more tough of ue5 g5 this is the the
key moment now if black takes white is
getting a new queen but black is just
playing King to e7 this is very nice if
white now takes on aged six then black
is stopping the pawns quite easily there
for example like this this and four and
everything gets traded the more natural
move with the move g6 and also the one
that all the computers give and now just
came to have six King be for yeah like
it's just jet is giving away that pawn
it's absolutely check of new use before
can't change yourself and this is what
aronia net see that you get this ending
and this is a draw it's a fortress draw
White has absolutely no way forward in
the game there's still played up to here
but now agree to draw yeah the problem
is that it's all stalemate Jack Stanley
this is one there's also if black goes
into the corner there's stand this one
or you can if you try to I think let's
say practice here and I kind of shuffle
around yeah I wonder yeah this is what
I'm trying to say King edge seven
Stanley another one so there's
absolutely no way forward for white and
very nice defense here by Aronian who
found we have to really appreciate that
when he played ruby gf7 he had to see
this that this is a draw because after
Luke a6 there is really no big
alternative that night is attacked you
cannot go rook c7 and because 96 and
well don't want to move the night back
Johnny and something like that is
horrible
just do this yeah here check this he
simply had seen that rook F for leads to
that King and pawn ending which is a
fortress draw very nice job okay the
final game to look at is Anand to part
of the game between the two buddhist
participants
yeah bishop being honest it 40 44 46
right and to Paolo is like 41 this one
year younger than I am I often
calculated from my own age it's easier
okay let's see what happened in this
game oops that was the wrong one to pull
off okay let's have a look we had three
games not a single one four and here we
go
well that's the positive part the
negative one is we got a billion well
anyway I don't want to make fun of the
opening it's just a good opening and
well we don't get them endgame we get
the three-year ba island arguably
nowadays the more ambitious choice
Bishop c5 and Carol castles here black
has the opportunity to play Knight give
form and simplify a little bit which
tupelov is not going for I am NOT an
expert
really I have to admit that on that
opening but I think that this is not a
bad choice from
strategic point of view this is a Hydra
highly desirable move but it might have
some some drawbacks of a concrete nature
that I'm not aware of at the moment
often black is happy to trade those two
nights because if you compare this the
knight on c6 plays more of a passive
role and quite often you would like to
have a pawn on c6 to take away some
squares also if you don't trade you
often get the situation like in the game
that this Ponyo is looking at 2p squares
that the knight is 7
yeah directed towards and the knight on
c6 looks a little bit silly this is not
criticizing two paddles play I'm just
I'm just stating something quite often
that that trade can be beneficial to
part of councils Knight bTW - and now he
goes from Knight to e7 this regrouping
is not popular for a couple of years in
them in the Berlin and it's also due to
that reason that I already a managed the
knight on c6 is quite often not well
placed because those two speed to 2p
squares are covered d4 now and the
interesting point is that black is
capturing and going goes back it at
first looks a bit strange that black is
giving up his share of the center but
note that on whites from from the white
side there are a couple of things
not quite yeah not quite in harmony
Bishop on b5 is not particularly well
placed it will definitely lose a temple
to a move like c6 or a6 the night on b2
is also wrong white would clearly
preferred have a knight on c3 m2 being
able to develop the c1 bishop so white
has a center but the support of the
center is a little bit clumsy at
rook e1 and Bishop g4 we see all this
was quickly plated sir of course part of
both players preparation in modern
chance you very often have the situation
that players play M systems from both
sides to pawn off also has played this
from the white side in fact after 96 for
example this would have been a position
from top I love Nakamura from last
year's st. Louis tournament Bishop g4
ever also makes lots of sense h3 back
and now again to fall off now on the
white side again he had played Queen b3
also against Kawana and San Luis so we
have got a couple of earlier games where
both players were involved they also
aren't games but I didn't I didn't copy
any references in my notes and yeah a
form was played now here in this game
bye-bye Vichy and a6 as the natural
reaction and he goes back here rookie
agent now we see to pile of took some
time is probably now out of prep and a
lot as well all this looks totally
normal Queen b3 looking at the pawn on
b7 yeah black now goes for knight c6 and
ambitious move and a good move it's not
a bad move at all d5 that pawn was
attacked and 94 we see that black he is
getting quite nice active pieces the
only real question is what about this
pawn on b7
yeah and Anna took it he took the pot
this is not a mistake however after the
move Knight to d7 but Apollo do remove
the idea 95 now it becomes very very
relevant and here aren't
yeah he made a mistake it's just like
that what he probably should have done
is play move like [ __ ] a three or a four
these are suggestive as stockfish using
the rook also for defensive purposes if
black goes on yeah 95 here then Queen
before is completely fine there is a
clear difference to this rook a 3-2 what
happened in the game and we will see
what happened in the game an island
played the move Knight c4 and after
94-95 Queen c6
yeah note that there are not many other
squares if you go here this this this
obscure it's just too embarrassing so
you have to go to c6 but now this is the
absolute this is the key moment of the
game there are a couple of other
critical on once later but this is the
absolute key moment here and somewhat
mysterious moment as to par love was
really really well known for being a a
dangerous dynamic player now is not
going for the move Bishop takes f2 very
surprising he played this one but he can
take on f2 and after that White has a
very hard time to play this position
yeah what's the point okay White has to
take check the check of course yeah and
what now what only has to move g3
otherwise you're losing the house I mean
you cannot do this one yeah here check
even worse yeah so you have to go g3
there is no other book and now 1994 yeah
and we see that while is forced to give
them give the rook now give the exchange
so rupee form and queenie for
yeah and this position I mean it's very
easy to calculate and he probably he
must have seen that that's absolutely no
no way to believe otherwise but what I
don't get is if you see the position
why not play it because from here white
really doesn't have any good looking
continuation you can only select between
various evils for example g4 is an idea
check-check
the shuttle g6 yeah now white already
has to play awkward moves like this to
even yeah stay in the game yeah black
now has a couple of options the engine
points out something which is pretty
strong but I'm not sure how intuitive
this is for a human being yeah it gives
this move this yes and now I look at an
eight kind of mysterious the rook was
hanging so he has to move it and that is
to play here and start to attack the
best seems to be Roque three Bishop d3
and now what giving away the exchange
here black is better it's just the only
question is how much is it a huge
advantage or is system eligible for
white instead of G form there is also
nine - III but here black jack will get
quite a number of pawns and this is I
mean it's rook and three pawns against
two minor pieces any situation is not
totally clear I'm not saying that black
is winning but this is all just the
question how good is it for black is it
a clear edge just slide edge whatever
and yeah for some reason he didn't go
for Bishop f2 we played the move Knight
B 3 and after Knight be three things are
not clear at all Group B 1 and now
yeah probably he had to play something
something else
he took which leads to a wide advantage
there were alternatives leading to a
very complicated flame that I really is
very difficult now to to figure out what
the bishop g6 for example was possible
to attack the pawn white doesn't have f3
or anything like that this is very
strong Plex pieces are very active here
this is this was okay or even f5 was an
interesting option but after the capture
really black is better
so it's mysterious what what he was
going for I mean even instead of 90 X e1
they were relatively obviously better
alternatives I mean black is a pawn down
here and of course here you have the
bishop pair but c7 is weakened it's not
so clear what your what your direct
players Yahoo p8 and that pawn was taken
and yeah f5 was probably the last chance
to get something going
why does better also there but something
like that at least was stirring up some
trouble but it's difficult yeah it's
three pawns already but pure pawn count
why this white seems to win but black is
still reasonably active yeah he played
this however and now after rooks e2 and
93 White's material advantage is a bit
it's a bit too as a bit too steep and
they are also now some simplifications
coming up Queen to d8 yeah CC pawn is
also tagged Bishop d3 got the straight
end and the a pawn is very dangerous
however a couple of moves later Queen a4
rooty for here in fact I noticed some
yeah giving to Paulo some chances again
they both didn't have lots of time left
but still here the move Queen c2 was
winning and a pretty nice fashion queen
is attacked and if it takes a six which
is kind of the logical move then I have
five wins
it's very that's very cute the rook is
attacked by the noid and if black takes
we are forcing a checkmate check check
check check check check check
checkmate quite nice yeah I mean is a
long line but it's not easy and sorry
it's not so difficult to assess once you
have the idea that Knight f5 is strong
what he did instead on he took the Queen
and now after this he have black still
is under pressure but it's not as bad as
it could have been I mean that Quincy
two-niner-five was probably just killing
yeah a5 and now in mucho Mucho try and
pressure to Paulo place this and this
seems to yeah again lead to a loss
position Bishop c5 was a bit tougher the
difference between the two Moses that in
the situation here
white activator said black can actually
take the pawn and in the game are the
bishop before now this is not possible
hmm yeah his idea probably was that he
has a that he has Bishop f6 at some
point
but that doesn't seem to be so relevant
yeah
rooks III was played and now 92
yeah it's move 40 very difficult
decision the move rook if for seems to
be stronger threatening checkmate push
appear and now look at eight introducing
this idea yeah this seems to win for
white Allen's move is not so convincing
92 but it's still very very difficult
for black to UM to handle the better
defense he played Roxy to now to polish
it and after that it's definitely losing
but it's move 40 we shouldn't be too
critical here it's difficult to do yeah
okay this is what he did the alternative
was f5 which might be I mean I'm not
100% sure but I think this might be a
little bit tougher bit a little bit yeah
h4 maybe say Bishop f6 57 g5 and rookie
sings White has a very strong initiative
there with the rooks and what I have
what I figured that it probably should
win but it's not totally simple this is
much tougher than the game and ideas h6
yeah you can continue that line for
awhile like this for example ahead
trying to try to take it is not a
totally forced frost variation I just
want to show some possibilities
you know this idea ja ja no and white
will win this pawn this is not force is
a 12 move deep liner it just looks like
f5 is tougher
the problem is what he did is he played
this and now you see that 94 g5 is just
killing killing idea so the the
difference is that this is just losing
straight away and the other continuation
at least set some problems yeah
f6 was tried but that doesn't help
after h4 yeah ok 5 ok f7 the ideas that
this this is made yeah black king is
boxed in yeah what now what now for
black if you go up
checkmate this is the end immediately
and if you do something like the Adric
ff8 is also decisive so i'm g6 check
check me here's another mate yeah yeah
we gave to tupolev tried some
desperation move
check check check
spy checks but why it has yeah
enough enough pieces to take all those
pawns and enter black resistance so
allen starts with the win against Apollo
yeah this the first round I think is
really really important in such an event
yeah aren't starting with the win is
kind of kind of reminiscent of what
happened in the candidates 2014 when he
started with the win against Aronian
arguably in in that case and two years
ago Aronian was maybe the pre tournament
favorite or one of them favorites maybe
in there from Nick also was considered
to be one but yeah not beat the favorite
with white in the first round and this
started that excellent event for for the
great form of a champion from India and
again Allen Tia starts with a win so
very nice start for him after his bad
tournament in Gibraltar bet start with
Apollo and especially him not playing
Bishop takes f2 doesn't really yeah that
doesn't promising that doesn't promise
anything radium for him for that event
so for his fans I can only hope that he
quickly recovers that should early loss
can be can be very very irritating it
just yeah ups the pressure a lot yeah
you cannot avoid a second you cannot
afford a second loss in an event like
that because you're not going to win six
games and this makes it all the more
difficult
yeah so he has to get a win and soon to
to level the score to get the 50% back
and doing that without taking enormous
risk it's not so easy yeah okay I hope
you enjoyed the coverage of the first
round I'll be back tomorrow with the
second round thanks for watching